president Trump's longtime lawyer
Michael Cohen appeared in federal court
today to protect his file seized by the
FBI
he didn't win a judge rejected his and
mr. Trump's request for a temporary
restraining order that would have kept
them from prosecutors adult film star
stormy Daniel showed up and she alleges
she was paid by Cohen to keep an affair
with President Trump quiet here's what
she said when she left the courthouse
for years mr. Cohen has acted like he is
above the law
he has considered himself an openly
referred to himself as mr. Trump's fixer
he was played by a different set of
rules or should we say no rules at all
he has never thought that the little man
or especially women and even more women
like me mattered that ends now my
attorney and I are committed to making
sure that everyone finds out the truth
and the facts of what happened and I
give my word that we will not rest until
that happens thank you very much okay
that was stormy Daniels and making a
statement outside the courthouse after
the judge made the ruling today judge
wood regarding the disclosure of the
documents so Dana has some news today
obviously because this was something
that Michael Cohen was trying to keep
private and get a restraining order
issued to prevent the release of those
materials coming out right so the
there's a lot of things happening in
court today really I mean it's a it's an
entire unusual hearing because this is a
highly unusual situation to have someone
who is the president's lawyer to have
the Southern District of New York the
FBI do the raid get the information and
then there's questions of
attorney-client privilege so that was
what was in court today and one of the
things that the judge required was that
Michael Cohen had to say who are your
clients give me the list of clients
right and he said okay well the first
one you all know is President Trump the
second one is Elliot Brody you all know
that and the third one I'm going to keep
anonymous at the request of everybody
but when I keep it quiet by the end of
the hour it had been revealed that that
was Sean Hannity he went forward then
and said well actually he's up he
doesn't really I've never done anything
on my behalf legally but I have talked
to him from time to time on legal things
like real estate etc so all of this is
swirling around at the time when the
judge is saying
we need to have this information because
we need to understand what you want us
to keep privileged so that when the
teams are looking at this they know what
is attorney-client privilege and what is
not and that's why you had the
developments today okay and Greg I'm
guessing Sean Hannity issuing the
statement and on his radio show as well
saying that he never actually retained
or transacted with Michael Cohen in
terms of paying him but that he would
consult him from time to time on certain
matters and that he has eight attorneys
I'm so you know that he uses at his
disposal for a variety of different yeah
I mean both full disclosure I am a
secret client of Jacoby and Meyers at a
uvula accident with a piccolo but they
got me a six-figure settlement Thank You
Jacobi and miler myers who leave it the
shot to be part of a scandal and have
the least salacious part of it i mean
his his stuff is so common sense it's
like everybody I love this I loved it so
much you go on Twitter
everybody was convulsing with joy over
this news they thought oh we got another
scalp this is gonna be amazing
all these little blue check comrades
together you know hoping seeing that
this is gonna be the best day ever and
of course it never ends up being what
they want
it never is and it just deflates back to
Norman all that energy spent on hoping
that somebody you don't like it's
destroyed actually just shows how petty
you are okay all right so Jesse I'm your
thoughts and also you know President
Trump was tweeting on this saying how
the attorney-client privilege is now
dead in this country because of the
invasion here in terms of like privacy
and privilege and obtaining documents
it's a difficult case to assess because
you don't really know what these
prosecutors are after do they have
something on a settlement do they have
something about Russia is there
something totally unconnected so I'm
having a hard time really dissecting it
with that said just looking back from my
perspective it's very troubling when you
have these you know people rating the
law offices and home of the president's
lawyer the attorney-client privilege
that's a sacred privilege and it looks
like it said now at risk at the at the
same time it seems very aggressive and
dramatic for them to do that and if I
were the Trump team
lawyers I would say listen this is
poison the well we're not going to
cooperate and I'd be pretty mad at
Rosenstein to to sign off on that and on
the other hand it looks like there's a
double standard with the way Hillary's
lawyer was treated and the way Trump's
lawyer was treated obviously different
cases but it has the perception like
he's being treated differently and then
the clean team going through the files
at this point in this juncture there is
no one clean I don't trust anybody I
don't think the president trusts these
people I don't think Hilary's team
trusted these people lawyers are great
when you're in trouble and we're a
nation of laws and they can protect you
when they need to protect you but at the
same time lawyers when they want to get
you they can get you and I'd be I'd be
very upset or very scared if I had these
people knocking at my door and raiding
my offices and sometimes innocent people
are convicted sometimes guilty people
get off scot-free I would just hate to
be in the middle of any of this what are
they gonna find in your office Jesse
that's a lot of swag yes exactly party
boy emblems special guest yes on a show
well but but I interesting response to
what Jesse was saying it was a legal
warrant yes I know it was legal this
country the people's lives upside down
we look back at the special counsels in
Clinton and Bush and now this I mean I
think both parties can say was was the
outcome the way we wanted it or expected
it no I mean they've run people's lives
through the wringer a lot of the times
unfairly and when this whole thing
opened up we said to ourselves you know
when they appoint these people you never
know which way it can go and this
thing's turn sideways and again this
country has been turned upside down and
everyone's laughing at us wait a second
wait a second the country's been turned
upside down by the FBI and the DOJ what
you don't know where this thing could go
best against Gray's been questionable
for the very beginning I don't agree
with that but I do think that part of
the mandate given to Muller as a Special
Counsel was that if you discover
anything beyond possible collusion
listen it's part of your it was a very
broad man
president didn't like the appointment
but let me just say I mean so to me it's
a legal warrant and it by the way
involving several Republican officials
you're right who said there is
sufficient reason for the government to
now go into mr. Cohen's office hotel
room and home are they worried that he
wasn't going to be cooperative and give
the evidence well he had been so
operating up into me that's a big thing
and the second thing obviously for us
here at Fox this is a big thing about
Sean Hannity and you know the question
for me is why Sean didn't disclose this
earlier because in the previous suitcase
Shan says there's no third party he's
obviously referring the idea that Cohen
was setting up payments to women for
Trump and for Eliot Brody the guy who's
the RNC donor and we just I don't think
there's any evidence of anything like
that with Sean Hannity but why when Sean
was on the air strongly an advocate for
President Trump not saying hey I've got
a relationship with the lawyer I think I
think that's a question is that present
that Sean and Michael Cohen have known
each other for years I have this is a
theory I've not talked to Sean this is
my own personal theory I think that if
Sean were to be asked two days ago name
of your lawyers would he have said
Michael Cohen is one of his lawyers
probably not it was Michael Cohen who
said he's a lawyer of Sean the goal of
which I think is to ask the judge to
protect any conversations he might have
had with Sean and he's saying yes he's
advised me on things before you don't
have to have paid a lawyer in order to
have attorney-client privilege like I
could say Kimberly can you represent me
and be my lawyer on something yes
dollar so I give her a dollar from there
on then everything she and I talk about
can be attorney-client little one over
there great